and i'm not trying to make the most
amount of money but i'm trying to
do the most amount of good while i'm
here on earth because as we all know the
human mortality rate is holding firm at
100 percent absolutely yeah and so i
am looking at that and saying okay how
can i move the needle how can i be part
of the solution and not part of the
problem and sometimes actually doing
nothing is being part of the problem
yeah
[Music]
can you believe it i'm still here that's
right living inside this tent for 100
days from november 20th to february 28th
bringing to you the issues and awareness
that you need to know about the violence
on the south side of chicago but also to
raise as much money as we possibly can
to build a community center on this much
needed block called o block it's called
oh block because it's named after a
young man named od perry who was shot
and killed the gangs picked up the o in
his name and start calling it o block we
decided we're going to keep the o but
we're going to change it to opportunity
block i want to thank fox for giving me
the opportunity to come to you every
single day with rooftop revelations
sharing with you my thoughts viewpoints
and opinions as it relates to things
that are happening in chicago and across
our great country and every now and then
i get to share with you some special
guests who come to share with us on the
rooftop and today i'm really thankful to
have a brother who drove all the way
from san diego california if you can
believe that
uh and in the midst of a snowstorm in
the midwest when he got here and uh he
had a his name is dan powell he's with
us dan welcome thank you thank you
pastor and uh you know dan let's just
jump right in let's get to it i know you
had a rough morning
tell us about it uh my first morning i
was actually walking up to gunfire
and i counted 20 shots it was like
bam
and
i thought they were gunshots i wasn't
100 sure
and then about an hour later 10 more
gunshots and i saw you about an hour
later and i said did i hear gunshots
this morning yeah and you said yeah it
happens
quite frequently all the time just a
block away
and i was actually taken aback by your
response
because it kind of felt like to me you
were ordering a
oat milk latte from starbucks it was
kind of a matter of fact
and i was thinking wow
the uh
the response is it's almost uh numbing
yeah and you know and to hear you say
that
makes me
you know really think about it because
it's two things one uh i don't want to
normalize it because it should never
become normalized and i think a lot of
times with the violence in chicago a lot
of people become desensitized and
normalized so i don't wanna i never
wanna normalize it but secondly i don't
wanna be over dramatic because if i get
overdramatic then that means every time
i hear a gunshot
i'm going to be taken back i'm going to
be overwhelmed and and i'm living in an
environment where
it's it's often
it's consistent
and we're trying to do something about
it
and and so
i kind of have to stay even keel and
that's that's hard sometimes well before
i came out here i was reading the end of
the year report for 2021 and they said
there was over 3 500 shootings
and uh
797 deaths so uh that's almost 10
shootings a day yeah and 2.2 people
every single day dying from gunshots
and so if you're just doing the math if
you're good at statistics uh you can't
have 10 gunshot
a day and me not being here for a week
and not hearing one yeah and you know in
the month of january they had at least
30 women who were shot
seven of them killed two of them were
pregnant and their babies were killed as
well so we're dealing with you know some
very tough situations and so i'm really
thankful that
you came all the way from san diego
because
matter of fact tell us why i mean what
what makes a person come all the way
from san diego california to get on the
rooftop on the south side of chicago
what what what is that about well i did
lose 50 degrees on my drive i think i
left uh san diego and it was 70. yeah
that's our that's our winner 70.
and it's 20 now here
and uh the windshield's a little bit
worse than that and of course it's snow
flurries uh we don't get snow flurries
in san diego but um we met less than
three months ago i looked it up today uh
and uh we might you were a luncheon
speaker
and
god spoke to me and said
help this guy any way you can in every
way you can
and i came up to you afterwards i said
i'm coming on the roof i don't know if
you believe me at the time yeah and i
said i'm coming on the roof i'm going to
come up for a week
and then uh
i was thinking about that i was
preparing to come up we chatted a few
times and then i said you know i've
always wanted to bike
the route 66 which is chicago to la
right and why don't i bike back
and so that's why i drove out because i
needed to bring my bikes and i got a guy
coming out that's going to drive
[Music]
the van back and assist me and i'm going
to bike from chicago to la and it's
going to be all a fundraiser for project
hood you know yeah i think that's
awesome and i found out that not only
are you trying to help project good but
in the past you you basically have given
your life toward uh trying to help
people and i think that's important
because that's what project good is
really all about we're about trying to
help as many people as we possibly can
we're about giving back we're about
sowing into the lives of other people
and um
you know tell us a little bit about what
you do because i think
a lot of people who are listening in
america would love are going to love
your story about what you're doing to
help people well
i have realized and it's it's probably
been a revelation in the last 10 years
that
the more i give the more i get and
that's that's kind of trite but it is
true and
i'm living my best life right now
and i'm not trying to make the most
amount of money but i'm trying to
do the most amount of good while i'm
here on earth because as we all know the
human mortality rate is holding firm at
100
absolutely yeah and so i
i'm looking at that and saying okay how
can i move the needle how can i be part
of the solution and not part of the
problem and sometimes actually doing
nothing is being part of the problem
yeah
and it's easy to do nothing easy easy to
do nothing and i that's why i married
what you were doing i say uh this is a
guy that could probably have a pretty
cushy job in this in the leafy suburbs
and uh you know being comfortable yeah
and uh and i i get it and i i get your
integrity and your
uh your humility
and that's appealing to me and i'm here
for you whatever you need and uh we've
we've already i actually got some checks
in my pocket we've raised about
3 500 since i i left uh san diego but my
goal is to raise over a hundred thousand
dollars and i and i will say to the
viewers that while i'm here on the roof
i'm going to i'm going to match
every donation to 50 000 well thank you
i appreciate that we appreciate it um
let me ask you this what
causes you to
want to help project hood and not just
project good but people in general
because i think a lot of times one of
the things you just said i want to
just talk about just for a little while
is that
you know people it's easy for people to
just to sit back all across the country
people are sitting back doing nothing
yeah uh and they're they're watching and
they're doing nothing you know why is it
so important
that
we get involved that we do something
that there are people who are struggling
that we gotta we gotta get in there and
help all across america we gotta help
yeah
yeah well
i lived in la for 17 years
and i went live through the rodney king
riots
i lived through the og simpson murders
and then i left i left l.a i said hey
this is rough stuff and i
moved back to san diego which is my
hometown which is a little softer a
little quieter a little less graffiti a
little less razor wire protecting signs
and uh less murders quite frankly and
when i was sitting on my roof during the
rodney king riots
uh the plumes of smoke
everywhere and the the closest building
that burned was about six miles from my
house
and we talked about being dumb from
murder yeah
every monday morning in the los angeles
times there was a little column local
section
and it was a column about how many
people lost their lives over the weekend
due to gang violence
and it was anywhere from two to twenty
i'd say on average maybe seven right
maybe eight maybe ten
and i said i don't wanna live in a city
where
murder is just a statistic
and uh
i
[Music]
i'm not going to live
my life
saying that
yes you know this is a regular
occurrence this has happened about every
10 minutes is i don't know if it's going
to be a
police or a fire or an ambulance so
we'll see here in a second this is right
going right down
south king boulevard
yeah this is a continual type of thing
that we deal with all the time and all
through the night all through the day so
yeah that's a uh just a fire here that
was a fire truck so they're probably an
emt on that truck maybe somebody was
shot or maybe somebody had a heart
attack who knows but uh
i
i
i was born on third base make no mistake
about it i was
born in a middle class san diego
neighborhood
my parents stayed together
and i
i want to
give the type of life that i i was given
with a great education i was with public
schools through
12th grade
and then i went to private university
and i was fortunate to get a little
honorarium little scholarship to go
and i
i want to help as many people as i can
to
[Music]
to get the kind of life that i had and i
and i know that in the inner city um
there's some desperate people and
there's some people that aren't getting
a good education absolutely and and
that's tragic absolutely there's a lot
of stuff going on that uh i believe that
all of us can help that's one of the
reasons why i'm glad you're here i'm
glad you're participating i'm glad
you're staying on the roof i hope and
pray that
um we'll bless you as you're blessing us
and already happened yeah yeah in fact
it already happened uh before i left i
was in such great anticipation of coming
out here and it was it wasn't it was i
was i felt like the blues brothers i had
i was on a mission from god
and it didn't matter what mother nature
threw at me it didn't matter and i said
this to people i said there's nothing
that you can say or do
to keep me from coming to this roof
absolutely
well thank you you know i appreciate it
and i think
our viewers the people across america
are going to be inspired by the fact
that you
are so committed to trying to help us
and
us being on this rooftop i hope a lot of
people are blessed and inspired to to
not just help us but help anyone who's
in need wherever they may be all of us
can play a part can i ask a final
question real quick all right
are people so moved that they're gonna
uh go to project hood.org and uh make a
donation that's what i'd like to know
we'll see
we'll see i will say this that you know
we've been blessed and fox has
gave us a tremendous platform and people
from all across america i've met
wonderful people from philadelphia south
carolina louisiana alabama mississippi
the south georgia florida uh
has really been a blessing to us places
that
that you would think would not be a
blessing to the south side of chicago i
came through i came through eight states
and i would very few people i mentioned
what i was doing and they go there's
some pastor on some roof i heard about
and obviously
through fox they said is that the guy
you're going yeah that's the guy and
then some people are saying uh yeah i've
heard of this guy so it's really cool
it's a blessing so thanks for coming
sure and we got a couple more days with
you here and uh
thanks a lot my pleasure as i always say
america thank you thanks fox for giving
me this opportunity i am so grateful and
thankful and every single day i tell you
god bless you god bless america and
until tomorrow rooftop revelations peace
you